[Musique]
yakhi quoi y'a quelqu'un pas un paillis
des semelles de grèce allait appartenir
à un breton à bonjour monsieur je me
suis assez curieuse lui n'arrête sur la
tête
ah non là je vous arrête sa défense
d'une arête c'est une plume avoir dire
ils n'arrêtent pas ce que c'est une
plume de poissons ou alors c'est
possible
pandit dans ce qu'il fallait changer ou
au lait mettez vous à l'aise avec
plaisir
ac c'est une fausse barbe blanche d'une
vraie part expliqué moi que vous faites
pour la retirer si c'est une vraie
passionnée pas moins bidon je viens de
trouver un par là il sa part et vous par
hasard un homme non non ça c'est un
c'est un faux par certains faut parfois
ça fait le pas quelqu'un qui a trébuché
à terme soit possible ça fait longtemps
que c'est dans la région non je suis
arrivé hier soir en provenance de
londres
et quel bateau a su parvenir bateau
souligne ousmane faye les traversiers
mais on se plaint de faire oui pourquoi
match extraordinaire en bordel m'en vais
je suis arrivé que sept minutes de
retard oui oui c'est peut-être un peu de
houle
et oui vous vois moi êtes d'où abbas et
aux cantons de magas pas moi je veux
dire vous êtes natif doux à jeu suite il
avait dit six noms suis là bas où ça là
bas
eva joly landes avec né dans le nord de
l'île dans la plupart de l'île de france
l'île de france football
je suis bien puisque jossinet en ile de
france nord à lille à lire i will become
rouge voilà avec 200 wii et gaz mais il
ya longtemps que vous êtes là et peint
écouter ces personnes
j'avais trois ans nous étions bien je
vais vous raconter sa vie la position en
ballons captifs avec mes parents en
promenade
oui oui alors le ballon à survoler l'île
oui voilà
et mon père jeter du lest m'enfin ça
n'explique pas votre présence ici c'est
mon père était très bien mais bien sûr
et bah habituellement oui mais alors
qu'en ce moment pourquoi pas parce que
je suis poursuit par des sauvages
pourquoi vous poursuit-il
parce qu'ils veulent me sacrifier mais
pourquoi me dit vous sacrifiez parce que
c'est la période des soldes à ça les
potes la crise a marqué d'ici une
quinzaine ça ira mieux
ah oui pourquoi pas ce que ça sera la
quinzaine du blanc à bombay sa maison
oui oui dit non il y avait ce qui est
des bateaux qui croisent les environs
abbas et tenez gaz 16 ans il y en a un
qui est passée à huy alors alors vous
l'avez pas fait signe ce titre je
l'aurais fait ils nous ont pas répondu
si vous en dit dimon dit et depuis rien
d'autre ah si il ya la semaine dernière
y en a qui est passé à 50 mètres des
côtes alors vous l'avez pas fait signe
mais si non mais regardez j'ai nagé dans
leur direction et par tous et sa
remarque d'abord wings ah oui c'est ça
oui
et vous qu'allez-vous pas rester parce
que c'était un mirage mais en tant que
je comprends bien ici c'est pas
tellement touristique va pas tellement
pas tellement oui mais on parle on parle
et je ne suis même pas présenté je me
présente robinson crusoé non c'est le le
salève naufragés lui-même comme ça alors
province alors on va alors va jouer ou
demandé 2,6 un autographe salariés de
dire oui c'est pour qui enfin c'est pour
moi oui d'accord mais quel nom bah moi
oui vous voyez vous c'est vous c'est moi
je sais que c'est pour vous mais avec
veut dire à quel nom qu'elle n'a pas moi
une majuscule ou vieillesse à moi moi
moi comme je me vois la hausse à 1
juillet juillet vous avez pris du temps
bon et alors et votre prénom et nom
prénom oui mais ça je me rappelle plus
favorable que votre prénom maintenant je
vous ai dit quand mon père est laissé
tomber jamais trois ans oui oui bon
alors attendez voir quel jour
sommes-nous il n'y a pas école mais je
dis je dis moi ça fait prétentieux mais
bon voilà vous des bourbonnais demain on
fêtera votre baptême mais comment je
m'appelais vendredi havas d'accord à
demain et puis j'apporterai du quoi
c'était ça allez au revoir
[Musique]